bonjour giuseppe bettoni merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin avec nous sur
rt france l'italie donc impose de
nouvelles mesures ce matin est ce
nécessaire un renforcement notamment aux
frontières
bonjour à vous tous oui tout à fait
c'est quelque chose que les italiens de
dormir l'habitude on a enfoncé le
trouver tout ça la troisième dose à une
vitesse presque impressionnante
effectivement et et les résections cela
est évidemment là la grande des
commerçants surtout de tous la branche
hôtelière qui évidemment attendait les
vacances noël comme une aubaine qui
allait récompenser quelque chose de vue
de la période précédente évidemment le
test à l'entrée n'est pas grand beaucoup
les choses mais tout le monde de grands
enfants se cache un peu mal à un hobby
et continue dans cette direction donc
oui il ya une réponse est ce que c'est
pour contenir avec efficacité sas
évaluer mais évidemment encore une fois
le gouvernement tonnes et tout le reste
sa ligne parce qu'elle est la situation
sanitaire l'italie est un pays à divers
où le virus ne se propage pas autant
qu'en france par exemple pourquoi
renforcer encore davantage
parce que justement l'argument du
gouvernement et on a bien fonctionné
jusque-là à niveau bac 5 à niveau de
politiques de restrictions de public on
veut garder donc il y a eu une
augmentation assez importante on est
quand même revenu par le même niveau des
autres pays européens mais au niveau
d'avril dernier et donc on a quand même
presque des cadres d'une centaine de
morts par jour parfois on arrive à 80 90
et c'est assez un nombre important on
avait perdu l'habitude à ce jour deux
chiffres mais on est arrivé aussi à des
dizaines de milliers de casse parfois
donc on ne veut pas laisser la courbe
remonte des internautes est entièrement
on veut l'arrêter avant la politique est
celle ci désormais c'est à dire dès
qu'on a le moindre signe on a intervient
tout de suite oui on n'attend pas de
voir comment ça évolue comme c'est le
cas en france notamment cette période
évidemment des fêtes il va y avoir
beaucoup de touristes en italie alors
pour ceux qui sont vaccinées un simple
test leur permet de venir mais pour ceux
qui ne sont pas vaccinés il va falloir
une quarantaine de cinq jours ça
complique un peu les choses quand on
veut passer une semaine en italie oui
parce qu'elle a fait est la quarantaine
vous allez fais la faire à l'hôtel mais
noble hôteliers devraient être contents
parce que vous vous la payez vous même
mais finalement vous avez pas venir en
italie donc finalement l'hôtelier il
n'est pas content donc oui la
quarantaine particulièrement on s'y
attendait pas ça ça vraiment ampli un
contre-pied mais la volonté est nette on
veut un péché que la cour puisse
augmenter puis sera pas j'ai donc
l'entrée sans vaccin pas possible si
vous voulez c'est vraiment dans la
politique il faut être vaccinés c'est
totalement démotivant pour ceux qui ne
le sont pas et ceux qui ne souhaitent
pas le faire voilà italie qui fait
figure de premier de la classe justement
sur la vaccination est ce que est ce que
néanmoins est ce que les italiens se
plie volontiers à ces mesures
dans l'ensemble da la totalité grosso
modo si ce qu'a laissé lui tous ses
pertes ex à au début c'est justement
comment tous les adolescents se sont
tranquillement plier au fait de avoir à
se vacciner dès qu'ils ont pu ils l'ont
fait
la mettrons il faudra voir avec les
enfants mais on a un boom impressionnant
deux parents qui font vacciner leurs
enfants donc on a de quoi penser que
finalement tout le monde accepte même
les les protestations des novax il y en
a encore il y en a encore certaines mais
désormais ça rassemble vraiment quelques
centaines de personnes devant une mairie
et pas plus que ça on a plus de grands
mouvements qui était soutenu par
certains mouvements politiques aussi
qu'ils allaient occuper une voûte
entière et sert à rome là vous n'avez
plus de tout ça et donc effectivement ça
laisse convaincre les autres qu'il faut
se vacciner et finalement tout le monde
se bat pied est ce qu'il ya une certaine
crainte vis-à-vis du variant omicron
qu'en est il justement de sa propagation
en italie alors il y en a des cas qui
sont biens continue on n'a pas de grands
plaster au micro ce que tout le monde a
retenu pour le moment c'est que le micro
se développe très vite mais il paraît
qu'il n'ait pas autant dangereux que les
autres variantes
du coc vide donc c'est là quelque part
si vous voulez a rassuré elle et les
autorités ont dit on du tout de suite
expliqué même si c'est pas si dangereux
que ça ça va quand même ramener des gens
à l'hôpital donc il faut absolument
éviter cela et donc ont réagi à ça il
faut sauver l'intérieur de noël en
italien on ce qui est les commerces
n'ont pas eu longtemps dette qu'en
france par exemple donc c'est très
important aimer c'est jamais assez c'est
à dire que vous avez raison on a eu un
aide vraiment impressionnant tout le
monde soutient hôtelier restaurants
commerces mais la crise a été la
effectivement on persiste on ne veut pas
surtout pas un come on dire affaiblir la
courbe de croissance qui est prévue à
niveau national pour 2022 et le
déclenchement n'est pas le 1er janvier
le déclenchement c'est le 23 février
j'allais vraiment ses vacances là et l
italie qui fait figure de modèle pour la
vaccination est ce que vous pensez qu'il
peut il doit y avoir d'autres mesures
d'ici d'ici à noël ou d'ici au nouvel an
notamment dans les musées dans l'est
dans les restaurants avec les touristes
déjà plus que la quarantaine je ne vois
vraiment pas qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent
rajouter la seule chose qui pourrait
évidemment c'est le masque à niveau
public non seulement parce que
l'accoutrement vous l'avez que de la
haine dans certaines parties de
certaines villes donc on va récupérer
les parties plus fréquentés est ce qu'on
va dire désormais c'est fini le masque
par tout ça c'est possible mais je ne
vois pas je ne vois vraiment pas arriver
au delà
surtout pas un look down surtout que les
les chiffres ne sont pas là merci
beaucoup de josé pv tonine nous avons
fait un point avant avant ses vacances
de noël pour les touristes notamment qui
s'y rendrait pour les fêtes de fin
d'année merci beaucoup servi